awesome so i'm so delighted to have you
all here uh for our first
uh weekly data for the people so as we
mentioned this is a new initiative where
we're trying to
um
share these journal articles in a way
that the general community can
understand and so today i'm going to
present our
paper that came out that talks about how
scientists can develop these tests that
can test for covid19 immunity
now before i get started i was given a
brief intro but i kind of want to give
you a little bit more info about myself
just to highlight that even though i'm a
scientist um i do have many parts of
myself and i am also human and so i'm
actually from the united states virgin
islands
and i'm positive many people can't pick
it out in the map so i'm just gonna zoom
in and we're actually part of the
caribbean and so you probably still
can't pick us out but if you zoom in
even more we're south east of puerto
rico so if you take a quick 15-minute
plane ride
you'll hit upon the u.s virgin islands
and so i'm actually from the big island
and i say that in quotes because we're
only 84 square miles a population of 60
000 people
um but i think the thing i want to point
out today is that
we all wish we were there
so this is one of our lovely beaches um
on st croy and as soon as this
quarantine is over we're probably going
to find a flight to head home
but not only am i a virgin islander i
moved to the northeast after college so
i did my undergrad at the university of
the virgin islands so we're hbcu in the
caribbean we also had our own beach
which was amazing in 2015 i got my phd
microbiology immunology so here i am
with my mentor dr dana mordu who is very
instrumental in that process
outside of science i love beyonce i love
all things music um i guess you can say
i'm part of the beehive rihanna comes in
a close second
but i also love all things science and
all things fun so here i am with jeannie
our director at rocky to you and we're
just posing in really cool funny
lab gear in our yearly science saturday
event that's catered for children in
kindergarten through eighth grade
um but not only that but i do have a
small family so here's my husband and my
son tyson so this is in december um so
you are also somewhere warm so this is
in sync it's
which is another caribbean island where
my parents are from at our family
reunion
um but he's now eight months old and i'm
saying this because you might hear some
noises in the background and i'm gonna
try my best i isolated myself in a room
in the house um that
no one is distracted by the background
noise
all right so let's talk about this paper
so today i'm going to present this
research on a paper called the
serological assay to detect sars cove ii
serra
in humans and there are a lot of fancy
words in here i just want to point out
what they all mean so serological is
pretty much talking about the serum
which encompass which holds the
antibodies um in humans acid is just
another word for tests and sars cove ii
is the virus that causes the covid19
disease which i'll talk about in a few
and sero conversion is just the
transition from being infected to
producing antibodies against a specific
infection and we're all human so in
other words
all this is saying is that this paper
looks at developing a test to see if
people who have been infected or who
have recovered from this coronal virus
disease
and so we pointed out a little bit
earlier talking about like science is
collaborative it encompasses a many
scientists while working towards a
similar goal this one paper in
particular have not one not two but 19
authors and this is to show that this is
not a one-man show
and these authors are listed in a
specific order which highlights their
role in this paper so for example i
highlighted fatima aminat and fatima is
listed as the first author which usually
means she's the person that kind of did
the bulk of the experiments and the
analysis
um all these other authors were
instrumental in producing the rate the
data that they have the results and some
of the other analyses um and then the
last author which is florian kramer
is usually the person that funds the
project or oversees that project
and so like we also mentioned not only
do we have many persons working on this
specific science experiment but they're
coming from all across the globe and so
this particular paper encompasses
sciences scientists from new york new
york which is in our background
uh we also have scientists in melbourne
australia
in finland and in switzerland so i kind
of like to think of science as a
universal language but also it's really
cool to see that someone can perform
experiments in new york
and can reproduce those same experiments
in finland and usually get similar
results
so we've thrown this word out scientific
literature but what does that mean so
scientists usually
put their data package
recorded to the general public and so
these reports describe the latest
research that's been happening from
across the world but then these
literature have to be vetted by peers
and so our knowledge is shared within
the scientific community we never want
to work on a project and not share those
amazing results or those techniques that
led to those results
but the problem is with a lot of the
scientific literature they're usually
published in journals and these journals
sometimes require a subscription a
subscription which is usually expensive
or custom amount of money and if you're
not affiliated with a university it's
really hard to kind of get those
articles um but also a lot of the
journal articles that are on there use
very specific jargon that makes it
difficult for not only non-scientists
but non-specialists in the field to
digest so for example my background is
microbiology immunology and it'll
probably be really difficult for me to
read a paper that's written by or that
surrounds a project in you know
astronomy or astrophysics
and so
the thing we want to highlight though
that is indeed scientific literature
there's knowledge in there that directly
impact our lives it's the basis for the
new technologies that we see the
healthcare options that are given to us
but it also deepens our knowledge on our
own biology
so there are two different ways that
people can access these papers and so
one is what we call a preprint and the
other is what we call a peer review
so what's a preprint so usually
scientists can come up with their work
put it in a really nice
way to put it on paper so that others in
that community can read
now this is a really nice way that
scientists are showing this data in real
time and so they're uploaded to a
specific server and people in the
community including scientists can
actually read that paper and can share
feedback directly to the authors on the
paper um so the value is that you can
get it in a timely manner um you can
receive these the feedback from your
peers but also you can um it's a really
cool way to review what's happening in
that moment
and so but prayer review is another way
that scientists can share these journal
articles and so this is a process in
which these reports are actually go
through a process where it's vetted by
experts in the field so say these
scientists decided that they wanted to
put this paper in a specific journal
organization that organization would
recruit scientists that are experts in
that field they read through the data
they give comments back to the to the
authors they say hey this is a great
paper but can you please add on these
couple experiments or hey you know i
think if you added this extra stuff
it'll be really good but at this time
we're not going to accept your paper now
this is a gold standard for ensuring
quality and rigor but this process can
take several months up to years to
complete so in a time like now it's
really cool that we have this preprint
where we can actually see the data and
the experiments that are popping out in
a timely manner
and so this paper came from one of those
pre-print servers called med archive and
so this is just a pre-print for papers
in the health sciences in health
sciences but there's also bioarchive
which is a server for biological
sciences but i just also want to note
because it's not peer-reviewed they also
caution that these are preliminary
reports of work that has not been
peer-reviewed and we should not rely on
it for any clinical practices health
behaviors or should report in news media
as established information
and so this is where this paper um came
from med archive so i want to talk about
the styles of scientific reasoning so
there are many ways to attack a question
in science
and we can approach it in many different
ways now the one way that this paper
approaches a specific question or goal
is through a style that we call
experimental evaluation and so this
means that the study involves many
rounds of repeating those experiments
and documenting those results and it's
what we call a controlled experiment so
let's go back to when you're in middle
school or high school
most people have done a similar type of
experiment and so for example people who
enjoy growing plants right and you have
a question would my plant grow better in
yellow light or red light and so all of
the conditions are the same use the same
plant you water them the same they have
the same nutrients the only variable or
the thing that's different is a type of
light that is shine shown on this plant
so we have a plant under yellow light
and we have a plant under red light
you let some time pass the same amount
of time for boat
uh
but ways to assess the plant growth and
after that time you look and see what
those results were and so in one case
you'll see that hey my plant didn't grow
as much under the yellow light
but it grew a lot under the red light
and i kept everything else the same so i
controlled my environment so this might
hint to maybe red light has something to
do with plant growth
and so again this is what we call
controlled experiments and this style is
known as experimental evaluation
so before we get started on the paper i
want to do a poll so i want to get
everyone involved
how big do you think a viral particle is
all right so we'll put up a poll shortly
that everyone can answer so here we have
the question so how many individual
virus particles do you think can fit on
the tip of a sharpened pencil is it 500
is it 5 000
5 million or 500 million
so i'll give you a few seconds
for everyone to vote and then we'll
share those results with you
okay so we'll end the poll in about
10 seconds
awesome so let's share those results
okay so
52 percent of you who voted
actually voted 500 million about another
half 44
voted 5 million and a subset of you all
voted 5 000.
so the correct answer is 500 million
imagine that 500 million
virus particles can fit on the tippy tip
of your sharpened pencils
right but let's visualize that it's kind
of hard to like see it but i want to
show you
how tiny these viruses are so i'm just
going to go to this link which is super
fascinating to see from
the in utah university of utah
and it scales the size of things that
where we know about
um
and shows how small viruses are
all right so many of us have had that
cup of coffee this morning so we're
starting off with a small coffee bean
and we're zooming in
and we see a grain of salt
we start zooming into the unicellular
organisms like an amoeba and a
paramecium
now we have a human egg
we can now visualize as one skin cell
we have that tiny sperm going towards
the egg
a single baker's yeast
the x chromosome
we still haven't reached viruses
now add a single bacterium e coli the
powerhouse of the cell the mitochondria
the lysozyme which degrades compartments
in the cell
and finally we're at these viruses and
these viruses are super tiny but their
sizes also range with the type of
viruses that they are and if we zoom
even zoom in even further you'll see
some of the cells machinery in there
and one thing i also am going to talk
about a lot is this antibody which is
also really tiny
so now let's talk about like the main
topic at hand corona virus all right so
what is coronavirus like what are these
terminologies that's been used in the
media and so covet 19 is the terminology
that we use to describe the virus the
disease itself um so co
the first two letters in corona
vi the first two letters in virus
uh d
is the first letter in disease and the
first confirmed case in 2019
now this virus covid19 is caused by a
specific type of coronavirus and we've
been calling it the novel coronavirus
but it's officially called the sars cove
too narsar star stands for severe acute
respiratory syndrome and for those of
you who remember in 2002 we had a
previous
sars outbreak and this particular
coronavirus is actually closely related
to this tsar's code one so we've given
the name starscope2 for this novel
coronavirus now the name coronavirus
may be new to many people but these
chronoviruses chronoviruses have been
around for a very long time if you've
had the common cold chances are that
might have been caused by a human
coronary virus and so there are many
different types but this particular one
is a beta corinovirus and we named that
sars cov2 or scientists named that's our
scope too and here's a really pretty
picture i think has been circulating
many many places and you can see that
these uh proteins or things on their
surface kind of look like crown so
corona is latin for um
for crown and so hence the name corona
but how does this virus get into the
cell all right and so how do we get sick
so here's a image of the virus and i
want to spend a couple seconds focusing
on what this virus looks like and so
viruses encompasses their genetic
material inside of its particle in our
case for stars cove 2 it has rna unlike
humans where our like baseline genetic
material is dna and so this rna is
protected by a layer that we call the
lipid bilayer but in other words it's
just a layer of fat and that layer of
fat has a number of different proteins
on the surface now these protein this
one in particular and which we call
spike protein is very important for a
couple things one thing is that it's
important for getting into the human
cell so in order for this virus a
coronavirus to get into the cell it has
to be a really good match to the
proteins on our human cells and this
particular protein in this case is
called a human ace2 receptor so it's
kind of like a firm handshake so the
virus is like it disguises in itself
like hey you remember me let's shake
hands really firmly and once it shakes
your hand it like puts itself inside of
the cell and so the virus needs to be
inside of a whole cell in order to make
more copies of itself and this is why
scientists has come to a general
consensus of viruses not being alive
because they can't make more viruses
without the help of a whole cell so
these whole cells provide the machinery
needed to make many many more of these
viral particles which can go on to
infect more cells
but this spike protein also have another
role
and it has to do with the immune
response and so by now many of us have
heard like oh do we have antibodies for
the virus right and you know how is uh
how do we know if someone is infected by
the virus and will we be protected and
so i want to briefly talk about our
immune response to this virus in
particular so our immune response has
two players we have the antibodies and
we have the antigens so what the
antibodies are are these y shaped
molecules or proteins that are produced
by our immune cells so say our white
blood cells these antibodies recognizes
uh foreign particles and in our case
those foreign particles are would be
coronal virus thesaurus clove too
now the antibodies realize that
hey this is something i don't recognize
let's find it
let's bind to it let's attack it get rid
of it but not only that let's remember
this virus so that the next time it
comes around we can quickly clear the
infection without that human getting
sick and so the thing that these
antibodies bind is what we also call the
anagens so it's a a dual plaral so you
have the antibodies which bind to the
antigen which can one get rid of that
viral protocol and two it can send
messages to other immune cells in your
body to remember
this particular antigen so the next time
it comes around we can quickly get rid
of it
and so these two terms are very
important for this paper
not only are they important but we
actually have many different types of
antibodies five to be exact five main
types but the two i want to focus on are
igm and igg
now igm is usually the first antibody to
respond to a viral infection and igm is
usually
swims around in a pentimer which just
means five molecules put together
so it's like a five molecule complex and
the second antibody that comes into play
is the igg so the igm kind of like sends
messages to your body and your immune
cells like hey i'm giving you this
information to make sure that you can
capture this the next time it comes
around so igg is what we call the
secondary response to this infection
so let's talk about the testing for
coved 19.
and so right now we have tests that can
tell if someone has that virus and so
you guys have seen where
their videos floating around would take
a swab and they stick it down their nose
and they see if someone has an infection
what we lack currently our test to see
if someone has already had the infection
so on this scale we have the number of
days and we have the amount of that
particular thing that's present so
someone gets infected with that virus
and what happens is that viral load
increases kind of hint into the immune
system hey something's going wrong and
then we have this igm antibody coming in
that starts attacking this virus but
it's also sending messages to your other
immune system
and now your igg antibodies come into
play which is your secondary response
and it increases over time and we
usually call these people immune to the
infection because once you have these
igg present as soon as you might get
exposed to this virus it can quickly
attack it but how do we know that people
are protected from this virus or that
they have produced antibodies for this
infection
so this is where this paper comes in so
one thing scientists ask is what
information do we have so far what's
lacking what do we need to work on so
just to know this paper came out about a
month ago on march 18 and at that point
we
have and still do have tests or
molecular assays so it's basically a
test that looks for whether or not the
virus is present
so we consider that a current infection
but we don't know when that person
clears that infection fully and we also
don't know when they've produced these
antibodies that can protect and protect
them the next time around and so this
paper really focuses on like can we
develop a test to see if someone has
been previously infected with sars cove
to with starscope 2.
so what's the main goal of this paper so
once again they want to see if they can
develop a version of this virus and
they're going to use a particular
protein of the virus that can act as
that antigen that i talked about and see
if we can use that antigen to detect
whether or not someone who's been
infected um do have the antibodies in
their blood
so once again to reiterate our bodies
are really good at pumping out these
antibodies when we get sick in our case
we're going to talk about
sars clove too
and again these antibodies specifically
recognize the proteins on the surface
which we're going to call the anagens so
this antibody antigen complex or
interaction is very important for the
rest of this paper
so again we have this virus
and the thing with working with this
virus is that it's very contagious
you're putting people at risk and at
harm and so it's really hard for
scientists to take whole viruses and try
to use it to manipulate to come up with
tests and things that may help with
combating this current pandemic so is
there a way that we can use part of this
virus that are that can recognize the
antibodies in the immune system without
causing harm to the scientists or when
we're formulating these tests so what
these scientists did
is that they
came up with a way to make this
particular protein which is called a
spike protein in a test tube
and use it to figure out whether or not
we can use this one protein and not the
virus to detect if someone do have these
antibodies
but remember i told you these proteins
or these viruses are really small
antibodies are really small so
scientists have a really neat way to
actually visualize these proteins
and we call this a gel right for the
lack of better term and with this gel
you see a lot of blue markings so these
blue markings are all proteins of
different sizes that we use as a ladder
or control now scientists know by coming
up with the methods for this protein the
approximate size of this protein so here
we see the different sizes and kda is
kilodaltons and it's just a way that we
measure proteins
and so they know the approximate size of
the proteins but in this particular gel
all proteins that they're able to
produce in that test tube
would light up this blue color
so what you can see the scientists are
confirming that they were able to
synthetically make in a test tube
just that one piece of protein from the
virus
but now we have the virus which we'll
call the the viral antigen actually and
we have this protein that's going to act
as that and so what we want to figure
out is okay we don't have the virus
anymore we're not at risk but can we
take that small synthetic viral antigen
and use it to see if someone has been
previously infected with the sars cove
ii
so just to remind everyone when someone
gets infected with coronavirus the
antibodies bind specifically to the
antigen
in our case that viral antigen is now
that spike protein and we want to see if
your body's antibodies to that infection
can recognize just that small part of
the virus
so they developed a method not the
method itself but the way that they
developed it um is fairly new because
they're using new molecules or new
components but this method has been out
for many years it's called an elisa an
enzyme-linked immune absorbent assay so
how many of you guys have seen what a
pregnancy test looks like right or like
the hiv over the counter test they all
utilize this type of methodology to see
whether or not something is present or
something is absent now remember these
proteins our antibodies are really small
so the enzyme linked is a really nice
way for us to actually visualize if that
thing is present
so in the case of this paper we've
developed this viral antigen in a test
tube right and we have a number of
different samples from humans who've
been previously infected with
coronavirus now the thought process is
that in their serum which holds their
antibodies
if their serums are source code too
specific the scientists are hoping that
it can recognize piece of that virus
so in the test tube they add the serum
from the human um that's been infected
with coronavirus and if they have
antibodies that can bind that viral
antigen
it does so
but how can we see that it actually is
binding to that viral antigen
we have these synthetic antibodies that
have this really cool link on it
that can actually allow us to visualize
it in a test tube
right so after we have that binding
taking place we add an activator and so
it goes from us not being able to see
anything right so if there's nothing
being shown on it we're going to assume
there's no antibodies present but if
something is there
that's binding to that viral anagen
you'll see a color change
right so basically in this acid what
scientists are looking for is whether or
not this antibody are present so color
is there or if that antibody is absent
there's no color there
so what does this look like when we
graph it
so what they were able to detect is that
the antibodies from people who have been
previously infected were able to detect
that small piece of that virus that they
made in the lab which is the viral
antigen
and so i just want to hone in on the
axes
and so on the y-axis you have what we
call the optical density or basically
the amount of light that you can see
through a machine and so the higher that
number the more antibodies that patient
serum have that bound to that antigen
the lower the number the less antibodies
that they have towards that that can
bind that antigen but we also have a
background signal and so scientists
control for that amount
now on the bottom we want to ensure that
it is that antibody that's causing that
light signal so one thing scientists can
do is actually make dilutions of that um
antibody so that we can make sure that
it is the antibodies that are binding to
that antigen so what they do is kind of
like having a really sweet juice like so
we do this all the time i'll have like
the welch's passion fruit juice but it's
really sweet so i dilute it like half
and half with water so every dilution
i'm adding more water to it and so
you'll get to a point where it's super
diluted and you don't see a signal
because there's very little antibody in
that test tube
now we're looking at the different serum
samples that they're using and
scientists did a really neat job of
adding in these controls that i talked
about in the beginning
and so we have three
um we actually have four serum samples
that came from three persons who are
infected with sars clove two and so here
we have patient one two and three so one
and two are the red and dark red color
and you can see there's really high
signal
leading to the thought that these people
who've been infected with stars
coronavirus do have antibodies that can
recognize the antigen that these
scientists made in the lab but then we
also have this other patient so we have
at two different time points post
infection and you can still see that
they're able to read out a signal
ensuring that the antibodies from this
virus infection is showing up and is
binding to the viral antigen now what
are the other controls so they had about
50 other patients that they got serum
from um in like 2019 before the pandemic
reached the u.s and so these control
samples we can say that they've of these
control samples have actually been
humans who've been infected with other
viral infections so they've been i'd
have been infected with the flu they've
probably been infected with other
coronaviruses that i talked about
earlier and so we want to ensure that
this test and this anagen is not
actually binding to antibodies that
should be specific to sars clove 2. now
this one i think is really neat so they
added a sample of someone who had a
confirmed case of another human
coronavirus and that's called nl63 and
this human coronavirus is kind of
special because it actually uses that
same human receptor that sars clove to
have so they may have some similarities
in that antigen or on that protein of
under surface but you can see that this
assay is really specific because the
antigen that it produced the antibodies
that may have been in that serum does
not recognize an anagen that comes from
the sars cove 2 virus
all right so i've shown you that the
antibodies in the serum can detect this
antigen that they've made in the lab
all right so just to reiterate we have a
virus that infects humans and then we
have these other data points where you
see a production of igm and igg what i
did not show you was this test that i
showed you previously the results did
not indicate what type of antibodies
they were all we know that there were
antibodies in there and they were
specific enough to bind to that viral
antigen that they made in the lab so how
can we see whether or not it's igm or
igg or some other antibody that's
binding to this viral antigen
so what they did is something that we
call isotyping so it's basically just
trying to figure out which type of
antibody
is actually binding to
our excuse me viral antigen and so in
this slide i'm showing one data point um
where they
test and see the different types of
antibodies that were present and so the
two that i wanted to highlight were igg
which is so igg is present in four
different subtypes um and then we have
the igm just want to zone in on the
scale so these are 10 fold marks so this
is like a log scale and so
the amount here is 10 times higher than
the amount below so it shows us how much
of that is present and the x-axis just
shows us the type of antibodies and so
all of the patients you can see with the
different differentiations is that they
all can um they're able to detect igg
present and igm present
but one thing that's been going around
in the media so if you guys watch cnn
and you listen to cuomo
um or you know any other news outlet you
hear them talk about like we need to
make sure that these antibody tests when
we want to bring them out are really
good and not going to give us any like
you know
bad information so one thing that these
scientists want to make sure is that
this test
is both specific
and sensitive so what do i mean by that
so specificity and so we want to make
sure that if someone else has been
infected from another viral infection if
they were to take their tests it's not
going to come up saying that they have
antibodies to it when it's not the
actual virus infection that we're
looking for
so in this case what these scientists
did remember i told you that they also
tested someone with a confirmed human
coronal virus case that bound to the
same receptor but this test was so
specific that it did not show any light
meaning that the antibodies in this
patient's serum did not bind to the
viral antigen that came from the sars
cov2 once we can ensure that this test
is specific we can then reduce the
amount of faults positive so we don't
want the test coming up positive when in
actuality you had a human chronovirus
you go out into the population and
thinking that you're immune but in
actuality it was just another
coronavirus that you had
now the authors also try to talk about
like sensitivity so sensitivity meaning
like how soon can we detect if this
person was able to produce antibodies to
this infection so if this person got
infected say two days ago is this test
sensitive enough to pick up on maybe the
little bit of igm that's being produced
and so i just highlighted one of these
serum samples this person was infected
about the this the serum was taken from
this patient about day four after
infection and you can see that there is
ign present that they were able to
detect and there's also igg present and
so it does seem to be able to pick up
antibodies that may be coming in early
in infection and so once your test is
super sensitive you actually reduce the
amount of false negatives that you have
so you also don't want someone going out
and be like oh the test came out
negative you know i didn't get infected
with coronavirus um and then you know go
out and are susceptible to the thing and
you know maybe they were already
infected with stars clove too
but this paper i only show you some of
the main data points but this paper
actually did a number of different
things and i kind of want to zone in on
the process of science like this this
didn't come about in like a day or
overnight right it took some time it
took some trial and error and so these
scientists actually try to produce this
viral antigen so part of that virus in
different types of cells right so
different types of cells we can hijack
the machinery in those cells to kind of
make the protein of interest
and i did not show that data these
scientists also try to make different
versions of this anagen right so not
only could you make the full spike
protein maybe just make the small tip of
it and see whether or not that works and
so i didn't show that but the spike
protein actually worked better in their
assays or their tests other than the
versions the other versions that they
tried to make
um i mentioned that in this study they
only tested four samples from three
patients so i also want to point out
that this paper was just to develop the
assay and it was not a clinical trial so
what scientists can do they can take
this information that was on his paper
and use it in a clinical trial where
you're testing a larger number of humans
to see if this test does actually
recognize on a broader scale
and what i really love in this paper is
that they make this point and this is
what i really like about med archive
even though it's not gone it has not
gone through the peer review process is
that we're all working towards a similar
goal we're all really trying to get over
this pandemic as soon as possible and go
back to what used to be normal right and
so at the end of the paper they made
sure that they stated we are making all
the methods and reagents widely
available to the research community in
order to support this global effort to
limit and mitigate the spread of stars
cove 2. and i just know a lot of people
think that you know we like work in a
laboratory we don't want anyone else to
have this information but in reality
this is such a collaborative effort that
we're pumping out this data and we're
putting out the papers on there so that
other scientists can go into their labs
utilize the methods that they have and
see if they can even perfect that
so what does what this look like in the
future so i spoke about their testing
that are available but none of them are
fda approved yet and so i actually found
there two companies um websites that
actually already have this antibody test
all right so this is what it looks like
um if anyone has taken a pregnancy test
before it looks very similar to this
um and so on the test strip you have a
control line and so having a control
you're ensuring that the test works so
you're making sure that there's
something that's um consistent in
everyone's blood or serum so this test
is actually a prick on your finger so
you prick your finger and you put the
blood in the test and so if this light
comes up you know that the test works
now you can also have a result that's
ign positive so remember i said that igm
is that antibody that responds first to
this viral infection right and usually
if someone is igm positive that means
that they're probably still fighting off
that infection so this person is
starting to produce those antibodies but
still have the virus present in their
bodies so you shouldn't leave home right
you shouldn't leave whom either way
unless you're essentially employed um
but we also have a test that could be
igg positive and so what igd-positive
remember i mentioned that this igg is
the second one to come into play and
usually at that point you've already
cleared the infection and you can make
the assumption that you are immune to to
infection so you're not susceptible and
so these are the patients that we're
talking about in the news outlet
especially for healthcare professionals
like okay you've recovered from this
virus you have the igg you're immune but
not only that a lot of people who have a
lot of igg present we can actually
utilize their serum to help save the
lives of people who are trying to
recover from this illness and then you
can be in a phase where you're igm
positive and igg positive and this just
means that we're not too sure whether or
not you've cleared the virus completely
because two antibodies are present
and one thing i also want to point out
is that the test uh the site also
mentions that
this test is not necessarily as specific
as it should be um so they say that
these positive results may be due to
past and present infection with another
coronavirus strain that i've talked
about previously and the one that they
mentioned that i want to highlight is
that nl63 which is a human coronavirus
that also binds to the same human
receptor so
um this is why i think the fda is
holding out and improving some of these
tests because you don't want people
thinking that they are immune to it go
out get the disease and can um spread
that to someone else
so moving forward at this point we have
the testing available to see if people
have current infection with the virus um
granted there's all this debate and
argument about like making that
accessible to everyone um but also
pointing out that remember even if you
don't have symptoms that doesn't mean
that you're not infected with the virus
and i think this is why social distances
is really important with the test that
we currently have because we have no way
to test if someone has developed
immunity to this current affection and i
think scientists are working really hard
and it's not a matter of like you know
if we're gonna have that test but i
think it's like when is that test gonna
be sensitive and specific enough so that
the general population can test and see
whether or not they've already recovered
from that virus and they're protected
for some amount of time
so that's all i have thank you and i'll
be more than happy to take on any
questions